hello
oh
strange Loop uh thank you for coming to
strangeloop thank you for coming to this
talk
specifically
uh we know you have a choice when you
fly strange Loop and we appreciate you
being here
um
let's do the talk
so
I'll start with saying a little bit
about my background uh I come from
Comedy writing
I spent a few years writing and editing
for click hole in the onion and since
then I have moved toward creative coding
and part of this talk is a story of how
that happened
shout out to the RC sent the recourse
Center RC and to botnik which you'll
hear about later
so in this talk I'm going to start with
a kind of personal history of
coming to coding through predictive text
and then talk about small language
models on small Source texts and some of
the reasons we might be interested in
those
and then we'll talk about how decisions
made when designing models can affect
the scope of the creative output
and then we'll close with some karaoke
that will hopefully hopefully bring
everything together nicely
and one theme I think we will return to
throughout this talk is the question of
what do small language models do well
especially in a world of ever larger
language models
so we'll start with the predictive text
and when I think of predictive text the
first thing I think of is this screen on
every phone for more than a decade now
it feels like and certainly on every
phone that I knew of in 2015
that has these three options at the
bottom suggesting words you might want
to type next
and it was in 2015 that I started
experimenting with this game
where you keep on just taking one of
these options and blindly accepting the
suggestions from The Ether from the most
boring person you could possibly imagine
we can go I
and
a
very nice and warm and sunny day of
school
and I remember trying this and
immediately only wanting to write like
this
and asking the question of how far can
this take me could this lead to I don't
think I was asking the question of this
could this lead to a world killing
artificial intelligence back then but
could this lead to a lot of fun was a
question on my mind and the first song
I'm going to play for you today is a
song written using these rules you're
only allowed to take suggestions from
the predictive text on a 2015 Android
phone
and you can take as many shots at
writing the sentences as you want but it
has to be a direct line of words from
the phone so this is a song called I
have a great time with you
I like to think it's a pop song
[Applause]
I have been working in an email with
powerful spam
it's forward this email and destroy all
the best of my friends
and your mom and dad's birthday party
for her birthday and she said it was
great seeing the pictures of my resume I
have a great time with you
I have a great time in my head I have a
great time in my head and neck and
shoulder and the rest
I am not sure how much you want me
and my dad
I am not sure how long it took me to get
to see the large annoying ads
I have been working an effort
dreamline my name
you are doing great and I am going on
the same I have a great time with you
I have a great time in my head I have a
great time in my head and neck is stiff
and sore and tired of spam
[Music]
thank you for your time in the future
and the rest of the day and night and
then the other day and night and then
the following New Year and then the rest
of the day and night I have a great time
with you
I have a great time in my head I have a
great time in my head and neck is stiff
and sore and stiff and sore and stiff
and sore and still stiff competition to
win this thing called the police
and Fire
and ice cream cheese frosting and the
rest
[Applause]
thank you
so that's what writing with predictive
text is like
as I said it feels like merging Minds
with the most boring person in the world
and this led me down the rabbit hole
that led to here and it started with
understanding that each of the
suggestion Pages you see was strictly
determined by the last two words that
you see in your input pane so if you
have the same two words I noticed you
would always get the same two
suggestions and if this holds then we
can model this exploration of the
predictive text space as kind of
exploring a maze where every every
Branch we can explore one of three
different paths
and if I choose is stiff as the next two
word node that I go to it gives me three
more two word nodes and then I choose
stiff and it's the next word node that I
go to
and we can keep going with this and
eventually it connects back to itself
and we can see how we got into that rut
there in the middle of the song
and then we can also see how we can
break out of it stiff competition to win
this thing called the police
and fire and ice cream cheese frosting
so
this is very similar in structure to a
model of sequences called a Markov chain
or a Markov model but let's ask is
predictive text as played on the phone
actually a Markov chain the formal
definition of a Markov chain says in
order for it to be markovian it has to
have a set of discrete States here the
states are A and E and we have to have a
set of discrete transition paths between
those states that are fixed and known
and we have to have the property that
the transitions between these states
depend only on the current state
so with phone predictive text it's
almost true but while we have discrete
States and fixed transition paths the
fact that the transitions depend on my
choices about which one to go to next
means it doesn't have this
memorylessness that characterizes a
Markov chain
I am the problem that causes it not to
be quite as elegantly modeled
um
so this experiment led me to want to
merge Minds with someone else other than
the most boring texture that could be
synthesized from whatever data set the
Android phone was using in 2015 and so
the next section is dedicated to small
models and small Text data sets
um
we could first ask okay what's the
simplest way to build one of these
Markov models
and this introduces us to the idea of
engrams where an engram is a sequence of
n letters or n words and tokens in
general from a text
and if you had a source text
that had this phrase I have been
then you might
take this stretch of the text and say
this is a three letter a three word long
engram
that begins with the context of I have
and one of the possible continuations
from that context is the word Bean
we can write this up
in well I think this is maybe a point
about small language models I want to
make is that because they are small they
are great tools for introducing yourself
to a new language and this was not this
was not the first draft of an engram
model but it is the shortest draft of an
engram model that I've written in Python
and it really only takes maybe a
surprisingly maybe not surprisingly
short
number of lines to get to a minimal
engram model of language all we need to
do is split the text on Spaces get
engrams of different lengths so 1 grams
2 grams and 3 grams unigrams by grams
and trigrams are the counts of how many
times words occur in the text overall
that's that's the simplest model you
could have and running just that one
would be equivalent to just randomly
choosing words from a bag
um
bikrams are modeling it as we only have
a context of size one and there's always
a continuation of size 1 and trigrams
are what we saw in the last slide
so combining these we can get to a
minimal engram model where you always
are taking the last one or two words of
the text and asking in the text we have
seen so far
what words followed those contexts
and I'm going to just jump out of this
presentation
to show
a working demo of this where we have
a Jupiter notebook and we can paste in a
source text which I will paste in
a collection of abstracts from all
strange Loop talks ever given
we can put that in the cell as the
source text
we can run all
and then if we scroll down a little way
we should get to a little Loop
where we are always getting a list of
nine common words
and by choosing one of these words let's
choose
the
we then get nine more words
so the language
is
not
necessary
that's a pretty concise abstract that
kind of absolves itself of needing to
write more
um
we can also expand this to a little UI
demo that we can more nimbly navigate
and that doesn't require constantly
shifting our attention and handling
collab this Workshop will
offer
some
practical
problems based on several important
factors
so
maybe you're getting the picture
uh
this is a minimal engram language model
let's resume
will this take us back to the same place
great
another component of small models and
small data is where do you go to get the
data
one option is to find it
another option is to ask for it so this
is an email I sent to Alex three weeks
ago thank you Alex for responding to my
my I guess strategically idea request
seems like seems like a way of easing
someone into the idea of giving you
Source text
but my favorite way to get Source text
has been using scrapers web scrapers
which
I love partly because they are so
fragile and so dependent on the
structures of this of the websites that
they are scraping so I found that over
the years as I've wanted to get uh
reviews from Yelp or uh Craigslist ads
or reviews from Amazon sometimes the
websites change and you can no longer
assume that the search page for
descending ratings for a certain
business is going to be formatted this
way and so you have this scraper that
represents a temporary kind of tenuous
connection to the data you're after but
they work and they get they get the job
done
so one example
that I'm going to read briefly from
pulled with this Yelp scraper is a
negative review of the Statue of Liberty
written by collecting the surprisingly
hundreds of negative reviews of the
Statue of Liberty available on Yelp
here's how it goes
I have experienced the Statue of Liberty
for the only time
the boat ride is nice but it took over
five minutes to even reach the statue
I had a few options I can go into the
pedestal and just admire the tickets I
had prepaid for
I can read up on Liberty and Ellis
Island
I can sit inside the boat and just smile
I have been too many things in the Dead
Heat of time
I guess I can get good in the freezing
cold of the raindrops
the statue itself was a little confused
and kind of just stood there
we waited maybe 10 minutes before
getting hit with a major bummer the
Statue of Liberty was a rip-off of the
Statue of weather
that's my reading thank you
something I want to point out about
how this how about the the process here
is
by wandering randomly through these
Source texts you sometimes get to learn
surprising things about what seemed to
be consistent patterns in the texts and
one of my favorite ones here is this
line in the second to last paragraph oh
no the last paragraph the statue itself
and this this formulation of the
something itself turns up in a bunch of
different Yelp review contexts where we
have
what you get to infer from that is like
Yelp reviews are composed of a preamble
where we're talking about all the stuff
around the event we care about and then
we switch and we say but here's the real
deal about the Statue itself or the
museum itself or what have you and I I
this is one thing I love about knowing
that this text came from a specific
place is knowing that the patterns I see
are not that far removed from the
patterns that are actually occurring in
the text and I feel a closeness to the
people who wrote that text and I feel
like
I get to celebrate them for realizing
that there's a distinction between all
the stuff around a thing and the thing
itself
another thing I like about small
language models that they do really well
is they are quick to design and quick to
titrate combinations of different Source
texts so that's something that I'm going
to Showcase in a moment here with
another song this one combining two
scraped or found Source texts Morrissey
lyrics on one side
and Amazon customer reviews of the
P90X workout system
a series of DVDs to make you beautiful
So This song is called bored with this
desire to get ripped
[Music]
the same thing every day is like a
workout for my mind
so I'm a marathon runner
in my sorry way so will I be a wonderful
shame after completing the 90s
I was wasting my money and my overall
health on a government scheme designed
to push myself to die I gained an
ancient ocean and I cried because I
could
[Music]
results I really started to cry
and I think it's fair to say
I've gotten bored with this desire to
get ripped
when Jesus started using the DVD
I don't care I just needed to get back
to my room I'm so sickened oh my God it
really works
I was skeptical
[Music]
during my CrossFit craze
times the one I was in third grade
slow workouts themselves are insane but
not impossible why don't you ask me what
else can I find
and I think it's fair to say
I've gotten bored with this desire to
get ripped
and I wish I could have read it
somewhere written in a gym I've gotten
bored with this desire to get rid
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
so they're we're now adding things to
the world and not just mimicking them we
have a combination of Morrissey and
these unsuspecting Amazon customers who
never knew they would be co-opted into
something like this
uh I want to take the next section to
talk about the effects of your choice of
tokenization
on the creative space that you are
exploring with generative models
so a couple years after the first
predictive text experiments I started a
collective slash company called botnik
which experimented with predictive text
and other generative methods and we
tended to take an approach where we
start with a source text
do some modeling on it have an editorial
process where we we filter it through
ourselves and then produce the output
oh there you go so Corpus model
editorial process where the people are
kind of suspiciously neural net
node-like and then production actually
making it and showing it to people
and I want to zoom in on the model part
of a botnik project
and talk about two botnik projects one
is this fake chapter of Harry Potter
called Harry Potter and the portrait of
what looked like a large pile of Ash
and the
choice of tokenization here is Word
level so we are using full words from
the source text it's very similar to the
the stuff we've just been looking at for
the last 10 minutes
and uh and one result of this is that
the character names stay intact so we
are going to be using full character
names from the source and we sort of
have that guarantee that in this world
that people know the names of a lot of
the characters we will uh we will be
mentioning them correctly I guess
contrast this with another botnik
project a Coachella poster where the
goal is to generate
band names
based on a source text of thousands of
band names I think we chose the ones
that Pitchfork had reviewed
and in this case it was very important
that we chose we used a neural net to
just spit out lists of thousands of band
names but you could use a neural net
with different sequences than characters
but in the case of band names it's very
important that you do go down to the
Character level because part of what
makes a band name a band name or what
can make it distinctively banned name me
is that it's not a word and wasn't in
the source text and it's like a made up
thing that no one's ever seen before
so with the word level generative
process you could never have a band like
giraffix or boy slash boys making
experimental use of punctuation or been
more extramploson
or plague brag or food thoid these would
never come up if you chose to tokenize
on the word level so in this case it was
very important that we did go sub Word
level
um okay next section is about some
theories of why language models are fun
or what we're enjoying about them one
Theory I have is that language models
confirm or at least feed our suspicion
that the real world is fake this is a
list of bands from real Coachella 2023
and I don't know of any of you have ever
heard of Danny Lux or uh
over mono or the sleeford mods or Pasa
but I never have
or if in the course of daily life we are
confronted by a poster that tells us
Danny DeVito is dorgle
are we just supposed to accept this
or if we get an email that tells us you
can earn five dollars when you pay for
Chegg with venmo
it's asking you to be pretty receptive
and adaptive
um so if this is what the real world is
like and it doesn't look that different
from what language models make then
maybe we have a friend in language
models Whispering yes your right to be
confused or maybe
we have a teacher in language models
that can teach us acceptance because a
language model would say yes
Danny DeVito is durgle
yes I will earn five dollars when I pay
for Chegg on venmo
and then it will ask us did you hear
fanch is headlining Coachella
or maybe
language models are conspiracy theories
because we know that they're models we
know that they are simplifying and
really not thinking in the same way that
we are thinking and so if a small
language model is able to produce what
we're seeing in the world maybe there's
someone high up there who's cheating and
instead of thinking they're just saying
words that they heard or making up words
that look real
a language model seen this way is an
accusation that someone or something is
acting without thinking and the choice
of tokenization confirm it informs the
specific type of accusation that we're
making so if we say you sound like a
character level neural network we're
saying one thing
and if we say you sound like a word
level neural network you're saying
another thing we might we might be
saying you've just found these words
that seem to get you far in the world
and it's not gonna we're not going to
take it anymore
uh yet another framework for thinking
about language models comes from Emily
short
who gave a great talk on procedural
generation and what is interesting about
procedural generated text procedurally
generated text and she has a framework
of five different uh ideas that come
from working with machines and
co-authoring things with machines we
have salt that's about fixed structures
that come from the way that the the
generator
uses templates Venom is jarring turns of
phrase like uh the Dead Heat of time
maybe from the Statue of Liberty one uh
Beeswax is many authors combining to
make one work mushroom is the tendency
to repeat oneself that comes from using
a generative model and egg is about this
human feedback cycle I want to focus
just on beeswax for a little bit
and notice that there are different
kinds of beeswax that you can buy in the
real world
one which we might think of as artisanal
honey is more like small language models
and the other that's like the dreaded
bear
uh from the supermarket
that contains more processed honey is
like large language models and there's
something
even if these are giving us some version
of the same thing there's something that
seems to matter to me at least about
knowing that this is connected to a real
world thing that maybe that this is
connected to a specific data set and
knowing where the words that I'm seeing
are coming from and not just being able
to explain it to myself but being able
to explain it with some effort to an
audience
um
so if I'm looking for an a list of some
some good things about to continue
extolling small language models
um they are close to their data and
provide a kind of view of the data they
are easy to design and explain
they are fast to implement and to
combine uh
they make really bad mistakes sometimes
which I think is a plus at least in
certainly in the context of Comedy
writing but
maybe it's nice to be able to reason
about what
what kind of mistakes a model makes
might inform how you want to change it
and so it gives a transparency to them
and I think that they're also relatable
because we can see them struggling to
Grapple with the world just as we
struggle to Grapple with the world
and so you in contrast to maybe a larger
model that will be built to always seem
somewhat authoritative and friendly we
can
we can maybe feel that yeah just just as
I feel like I'm putting word after word
and not really knowing where it's going
a language model
freely admits that or maybe
involuntarily admits it but isn't good
enough to to trick me
uh okay this is a brief aside to give
you another
another sort of visualization of what is
happening when we're choosing these
predictive text words in the tree
we can think of it as again a branching
tree
but we can think of it as getting ever
smaller so I have a lot going on
in
my
life this was the this was the phrase
from that from that 2019 Android
predictive text that you saw at the
start of the show
and I actually think I explored all of
these branches and found what these
words actually were so this is this is
accurate
um but we can imagine collapsing these
into a thin point and saying once you
have made eight choices there are now
six thousand some possible messages
three to the eighth possible messages
that you could have written and each of
those messages is going to live
somewhere along that line
and we could even label that line with
the numbers that floats between zero and
one
and there's an analogy here to
arithmetic encoding which says sequences
of tokens are a float between zero and
one specific enough to specify One path
down this branching tree and so if we
encoded a sequence as 0.34578 that might
correspond to I have a lot going on in
my life or if we chose another sequence
0.59259 then that might correspond to a
different message I am so glad you are
doing better
um there's also an analogy to what
happens if you're trying to improve your
language model and make it maybe a
little more automatic and a little more
of a guided representation of the world
this is like in adaptive arithmetic
coding where we can change the size of
these ranges in order to make more
likely sequences more likely
so we can if I turned out to be the most
likely one to start out we could widen
it we could widen have within that I and
so on and so on and this might mean that
we need less Precision in order to
specify the output I have a lot going on
in my life which might be a really
likely output and so this is something I
sometimes think about when I think what
are better and better models trying to
do when they change the way that they
encode text one way of thinking about it
is at each step instead of just three
words we have all the characters or all
of the subword tokens that might be
available to that model we have enough
choices at every step that we could in
principle unlike this produce all
sequences and then our challenge is
sizing those those windows so that more
likely sequences are more likely and of
course it gets to the point where the
states are much more complicated than
just one word so at some point maybe it
becomes a less useful analogy but I like
it
okay this one's a bit scatter shot but
we're going to go through it real quick
uh inspired by Ted Chang who posted a or
wrote everything's a post I guess
um wrote A New Yorker article uh
proposing a lossy JPEG as an analogy for
understanding large language models that
large language models are like a
compressed representation of the
internet I want to propose a few other
metaphors that we might think about in
light of this talk for a text generation
some of them newer than others we can
think of
navigating a language model as like
moving through a maze of possibilities
we could think of them as basically
fridge magnets that constrain you to the
vocabulary of a source text for fun we
could think of it as a ransom note that
is rearranging a source text for not fun
we could think of it as a kind of
scrapbook of places we saw along the way
during our travels on the Internet or
through text
or we could think of it as a
kaleidoscope that is a view of reality
but is Shifting things around a little
bit and uh and fragmenting it
and in the last section of this talk I
want to explore this Kaleidoscope
metaphor through karaoke
where it starts with with thinking about
well what is the creative process how
does the creative process sometimes work
one story I've heard specific to The
Beatles is that before yesterday was
yesterday
it had these lyrics scrambled eggs oh my
baby how I love your legs
and then that was a placeholder while
writing yesterday that was changed to
the song we all know and love
yesterday's love was such an easy game
to play
and the question is whether we can try
to automate this with a minimal model
with a simplification of what's
Happening Here
and to do that I'm going to show you one
of my favorite resources which is the
Carnegie Mellon University pronouncing
dictionary
this is about a four megabyte file of
pronunciations of English words usually
they're North American English
pronunciations and it's written in this
nice format called arpa bet which is
both human and machine readable I'll
show you what that means so we have
entries in the CMU pronouncing
dictionary
it's surprisingly comprehensive at least
in my book has words that you might not
expect to be in there and we have each
word represented as the literal
text you would see the phones the
phonemes that make up that word and
they're separated by two spaces it has
fonts it has this is an example of
opening the CMU dictionary in Python we
can get the words in the phones
and then ask it what the pronunciation
of Fonzie is it gets it
it doesn't have everything we can ask it
the pronunciation of a gives us an error
but it's pretty good and it's going to
get us pronunciations of quite a lot of
words
and so
this is the backbone of a world
conquering
technology I am building called the
weird algorithm uh
which works like this
for every line in a song we are going to
find lines with similar syllable counts
rank them by phonetic similarity and
choose one
and then sing the new words
and I'm going to show you what this is
like with the example of yesterday
so let's open up the command line
version of this
let's choose yesterday where is it it's
under the Beatles
let's choose a source text that we're
going to use to replace it
and I'm going to choose one of my
favorite ones which is Craigslist ads
for vehicles
[Laughter]
and then we're going to play it
hopefully this doesn't get us blocked
from YouTube for copyright infringement
good luck
[Music]
close Sunday
come check it out at freshrides today
[Music]
stop and go rear hatch with hidden tray
this is a really nice Hyundai
linuses
my deliver elsewhere four feet
I'll get back to you ASAP
break or transmission
who it lost
just run thin below chassis now or every
day
good work truck run strong driven mostly
on Highway
anyway
[Music]
what you will need to drive out today
ready to upgrade your ride today was
running great
till Sunday
what you need to know and you know in
stock today
this will not last long nothing wrong
[Music]
all highway
why is it a good day do you say
this truck is ready for work or play so
most of them
our Highway
[Music]
okay
thank you thank you
all right
[Applause]
so we're a little short on time I'm
gonna run through some possible lessons
that we could take from all this
uh one the more positive lesson is that
poetry is all around you you might not
realize it but anything you see or hear
could be poetry a more Sinister lesson
is especially when you're online
you are always on the record
and anything you say can and will be
used against you in karaoke
a third lesson is that you could be part
of future poetry so anything you are
working on right now and committing to
the public could be recycled later uh
with or without your knowledge
and
I don't know all of these make me feel
conflicted but broadly I'm excited to be
part of along contingent line of
connections and these connections
include I want to acknowledge
an inspiration for this karaoke
generator is this Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Wikipedia titles bot which
scours Wikipedia titles and finds ones
that are singable to the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles theme and post them to
Twitter or whatever the site's called
now
um it's a joy
and even this is not the end of the
chain of acknowledgments we could trace
a linked list of citations that starts
with karaoke and goes back to the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Wikipedia
titles bot which goes back to an XKCD
strip about the same concept which
itself is indebted to the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles themselves which
themselves are based on Turtles and it
can go on
and on forever and and we should also
note that this isn't just a list this is
more of a graph there is the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles logo generator that
informed the bot or that was crucial for
the bot and based on the same comic
strip
and karaoke of course this karaoke demo
is combining songs and texts and is
based on the tradition of karaoke
and Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
Wikipedia bot is based on Wikipedia and
you can check the alt text for this
comic and it mentions linked list which
is a reference to this slide and so it's
all sort of
connected
goes around and around
I want to close with one last karaoke
acapella that we're all going to do
together and this one is based on a tune
that I hear is popular in St Louis or at
least known it's Julie Garland's Meet Me
In St Louis and I'm just going to show
you how it works to in this newfangled
interface I'm working on for karaoke
to annotate
Meet Me In St Louis
we're going to get these CMU
pronunciations and we can input well
this one that it doesn't know is Tootsie
wootsie
so we'll give it two stresses
and we'll give it these vowels
and that'll allow us to print
the representation of it but I've
already done this I've worked ahead
and using strange Loop talk titles we
are going to sing together Meet Me In St
Louis
with maybe in St Louis that is with
strange Loop talk titles as the source
text
so the song goes like this
meet me in Saint Louis Louis meet me at
the fair
don't tell me the lights are shining any
place but there
we will dance the hoochie coochie I will
be your Tootsie wootsie if you will meet
me in Saint Louis Louis meet me at the
fair
okay so that's the tune
now we're gonna do it with new lyrics is
this big enough to read
oh okay that might be a problem let's
just make it bigger then
how's this
better all right uh that's worse
all right here we go
one two three four if only I owned my
data the semantic web
becoming attack
I was getting physical
it will never work in theory it will
never work in theory make your mobile
apps accessible to all
I geology
foreign
[Applause]
okay that's it thank you